would you like to verbally assault
friends and strangers across numerous
devices with cross-play and let them
know that their hamster farted on your
hovercraft from anywhere in the world
I'm more of a hooligan I like a toad a
physical fight in a little bit more tell
me are you your own cousin you've got
three rows of teeth and that's just on
the top when you smile I can see them
tell me here's a question were there any
other mine shafts of violence you see
this is just the kind of verbal sparring
and interplay that you can have with the
game oh sure experience a deep
contentious battle system employ combos
criticals continuations doesn't that
sound exciting you withered ancient
saddle leather like piece of shoe Hugh I
don't like it I don't like what you're
saying to me right now that's what makes
it British verbally joust against your
enemies across four different testy
conflict scenarios and dynamic
environments play is unique six playable
characters each with their own
weaknesses and insecurities improve or
destroy all of the important
relationships in your life for the low
price of $1 9900 how many pounds on me
currently but I can go ask my mom she's
in the whole Sweden and the bills are
piling up but we might be able to work
something out that's sad but it's also a
bit humorous that's Oh sir smack talk
the British Way and now for something
completely different
you feel lucky chap your son walks away
says the fortune cookie
stop Wang a time you get back
all right that's enough stop being silly